hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video today is
Saturday January 21st 2023 and you know
it's a weekend so it's a nice day to
sort of go back through you know the
footprints during the week and you know
start to look for things you know do
your own research and you know develop
your own style of trading and for me
watching order flow provides in my
opinion the most direct and decisive
insights into uh what's actually
happening in the markets right many
Traders though they they tend to focus
on a variety of indicators that their
software packages includes you know if
you go to you know ninjatrader you can
just see I I use ninjatrader but if you
were to go into you know whether you're
using any other charting platform you
know you've literally got hundreds and
hundreds of uh indicators on here some
of these I have no idea what they do
um
you know and at this rvi I don't know
what that is maybe someone could RSI I
know Roc rate of change but you know
there's just so many indicators that
Traders tend to lean on when you're just
better relying on the order flow which
is not just price because you know I
hear a lot of Traders say well you just
got to follow price okay well order flow
is it's just it's adding volume to price
right so you're not just looking at
Price movement alone you're looking at
Price movement or Price action if you
will
um combined with volume so it's just
taking it price action a step further
okay so you know really when you're
relying on tools like you know macd RSI
stochastics DMI you're just you know
supplementing
the way you should be looking at the
market now again you know hey if you're
successful over time using you know
technical indicators like DMI or macd
you think you know keep using them but
you know all I'm saying is you know see
what you can use order flow for you know
if you could use it to help confirm
trades or you know or even non-confirmed
trades meaning you know you have an
indicator flashing a buy or sell based
off of you know a
whatever DMI and but you don't have the
complementary order flow with it you
know maybe you'll learn to not take
those trades it's all about adding tools
to your trading to help you become a
better Trader and what I'll be talking
about today is it's about volume okay
because volume matters right I know some
people say I I don't need volume oh I
just need I just follow price all right
I could just uh I could just trade on my
phone and follow what price is doing
okay fine that works for you great but
what if you can enhance your analysis
and in turn improve your trading by just
adding and understanding the volume
that's going through that's being traded
at price because you know there are
going to be instances for example this
is
um who I am right the mini Dao
at the Board of Trade so this is a 15
range chart and again it doesn't
necessarily matter what
time you're looking at you're like a
minute based chart or a range based
chart or a tick based chart you know
you're looking for those times where
you're seeing you know abnormally big
volume okay and again you know this is
not something that would appear very
often but when you're when you're seeing
it in the market and you could really
wrap your head around what is happening
then it's just going to make you a
slightly better Trader better than than
most okay so this is a perfect example
this is Friday
morning around 10 o'clock again is a 15
range chart
people always ask me what's better is it
a range based chart or a time-based
chart well it really depends on your
approach to the market you know you
can't control the Market's movement all
you can control is yourself and how you
do that is through the type of chart
that you're looking at okay
and you know I just want to make one
other point a little bit clearer for
some people that don't necessarily
understand it you know you're
ATM or your ATM anything are you
basically you're you're a risk tolerance
levels right your take profit your stop
you know that's part of your trading
plan is
uh what do you want to call it a result
of the type of chart you're looking at
right if you're looking at you know a
one minute chart you're going to have
different
profit targets and stop levels than you
would if you're looking at a 15-minute
chart right you wouldn't have the same
targets or stops you know on a much
shorter time frame because you know if
you've ever obviously if you've ever
compared a one minute chart to a 15
minute chart
you know in a 15-minute bar you can get
a lot of up and down movements and you
may be getting trades on that one minute
chart that you're just not taking on the
15-minute chart anyway I sort of digress
I don't want to go down that route save
that for another time but you can see
here okay this Market you know it had
moved up
okay basically from you know 150 all the
way up to just about 200 here this is
200 and what happens okay you hit 200
you run into some volume up here okay
Market sells off you can see there was
40 trading on the offer if it went bid
here uh 53 14 traded at 01 and it sold
off okay and it sold off literally
almost about 50 from this low to this
High you know I pulled back into you
know around the 70 you know 64.70 and
then it started popping back up okay so
you know 200 is probably you know it's a
psychological level
200 you know 100 200 in in markets like
the Dow are going to be these levels but
when we sort of came back up the
difference on why this in my opinion why
this Market kept moving higher as
opposed to here where it sold off
is it hit this level again 200 and you
know the first time you did have a
decent sized bid coming in here you
traded 53 on the bid you do have this
buying a balance of 40 here right you
have a buying and balance of 17. you
know that looks bullish right you say oh
you know I got this buying a balances
bid here for 50 but then it dropped
right price action dropped so it's not
just price action alone you know when
you're seeing yeah I've had some
aggressive buying coming in here these
guys are trapped right next thing you
know we're trading you know 10 points 10
ticks lower at 90. well that that's a
good sign for you to get short you know
to catch you know a nice move from 90
down to 70.
and then we make another run back up
here okay the difference this time you
still have that bind and balance at 200
you see the 50 Lots and again it gets
bid there so again you have a buyer
stepping into the market you had one
here earlier it just wasn't able enough
to absorb whatever selling was taking
place now you're seeing that absorption
taking place you see the selling
imbalance of 75 contracts now it's 75
and it's holding this time you'll hear
they did it for 53 it wasn't enough to
hold Market dropped here it's 75 it's
pretty strong it's enough to hold it
Market starts trading back up what was
interesting when the market came back in
here a little bit later in the next bar
we traded down one tick above where you
had that strong buying right I mean
earlier you had that strong buying but
just wasn't enough to support this
market then the market started comes
back up to that level
now these buyers are like hey you know
what we've got to defend this area at
200 Market
next Bar opens up around you know the
0607 area pulls down to 01 and keeps
going higher than you see in here right
this bar down here at the bottom of this
bar you're seeing nice heavy volume 48
42 I even 18. so as the market starts
pulling back you're seeing strong buyers
coming in here you know this is these
three price levels that's about 100
contracts right one third of this entire
bars volume basically traded between 10
and eight eight nine and ten four you
know 18 42 48 that's supporting this
market and if you're just looking at a
simple bar chart following price you're
not going to notice what is happening in
the volume right sometimes
it's one of those things in my opinion
you know watching order flow is a bit
like watching soccer right football
European football where it's a lot of
passing back and forth you know like
game looks interesting but it's not
until you get that you know that that
flash of Brilliance from one player that
gets the ball
dribbles up and scores right and it's
like that with order flow okay you just
see this you know a lot of back and
forth a lot of nothing happening but
then there's something you could really
sink your teeth into so to speak okay
and that's what you know looking at the
volume is it just makes it so much
clearer now a little bit later since
we're you know I want to just talk about
volume today here
um uh what time was it I think it was
around one o'clock but I can't remember
exactly
losing my mind in here
um what is this 12 o'clock
uh
okay yeah in here okay you see the
market got high at the time was 3 333
5 and
who came up here we hit this high up
here at 25. came off down to 80 started
coming back up right then we're running
into sort of a buzz saw stopping volume
I thought this Market could potentially
reverse and continue on down
okay but it it did reverse right because
you can see this absorption up here with
the 124 the 30 and the market reversed
back down and again it went from you
know the low of this bar is 12. it only
got down to O2 so about a 10 point move
before it rallied back up and started
making new highs
so I was like well Mike he told me you
know there's heavy volume you gotta you
know expect the market to react to it
okay yeah this is a instance where I I
would expect it people say well why why
are you including it in the video is
because
you know I I want you to understand that
just because you expect something to
happen doesn't mean it has to happen
right in in trading
people's opinions of the market change
you know we don't know the thing is
right when you don't know if the person
that is selling up here is taking
profits right I mean this Market had
been rallying
and you know they could you know 325 is
a nice level you know if they bought it
a hundred points lower at 225 yeah you
know they're happy to sell it at 125.
you don't know
why
there's a trade taking place you know we
could just surmise and come up with our
guesses but we're just guessing at the
end of the day unless you're involved in
that but what you got to do as a Trader
is you sort of got to prepare yourself
saying hey you know what there's a huge
size I'm expecting this Market to go
down okay and it doesn't really go down
it goes down 10 ticks which is basically
not going down and then it reverses and
goes back up to new highs now what was
interesting again at this you know right
around this level here where you had the
124 just draw that line This level here
is
so you had the seller here at 124. and
again I'm talking I don't know who's
selling
I don't know why they're selling but I
do know I got a strong volume there I
got 124 contracts
okay
that's bigger than a lot of the volumes
you're seeing you know seeing over on a
15 range chart seeing over 100 contracts
at one price level in the mini dial is
is something that you got to be paying
attention to
Market rallies up to new highs gets all
the way up to 361. starts coming off
okay what was interesting is you see
this 196. now this was 124. now this is
196 here so we just hit the high you got
a big seller coming in
this one 12 people say well what about
this 112 okay well that's on the offer
on a market that's breaking out the new
highs that could be just resting
liquidity there I'm not reading too much
into this one as opposed to trying to
read more into this but this 112 up here
in my opinion it's just resting
liquidity because you know it's just
sitting in the market right up there at
350 also a nice psychological number but
anyway we get all the way up to 361
Market starts trading down and you see a
big seller come in here all right close
to 200 contracts coming in at the 44
area right this is 44.
putting my hands together rubbing them
this is it we're going to sell off
because you know we just made a new high
which is you know nice to see in the
sense of once you make a new high you're
looking for Supply coming to the market
supplies coming into the market
I'm looking for it to drop down and what
does it drop down drops right back down
to this 25 area right here this time you
got a nice big volume there you got some
resting liquidity to arrest that move
your resting liquidity to arrest the
move stopping volume think of it in in
that terms and I'm not saying that this
100 is somehow related to here I don't
think so
but when I see even if I have something
very bearish here right this 196 and the
market drops but it runs into volume now
this is an area again 325 what makes
this area so important here
is we were just trading there so this
hundred Lots this bid so to speak is is
coming in
now it's not like this 112 that's
resting in the market or even you know
this 124 that may have been resting in
the market for a while as well as it's
coming up we traded 325 back and forth
rotate around it trade it above now
someone's coming in after we trade away
from it
and coming in pretty soon to support
this Market
okay so even though I got this bearish
information here
I've got bullish information
this is important just as this is
important now that's the thing with with
trading is you can't marry your opinion
oh there's a big seller here I gotta get
short and I got to stay short we're
going to sell off
you have to also be able to Pivot right
you got to be able to make that
change in judgment saying oh okay yeah I
had that Supply coming in but now I've
got demand coming in I've got support
coming into this Market someone's coming
in here to defend this level at 25.
and okay so if you're making that
that step saying yeah I've got some
support coming in here you know you have
Supply up here at 344. you got to watch
then is this Supply because we're not
too far 25 up to 44 it's about 19 ticks
if we're going to come back up here
is the supply still going to be there
because if the supply is going to be
there you're expecting to come right
back down to 25.
but
this is the thing right this is where
that taking it that step further right
that analysis
well you know you have you just had
Supply here like minutes ago right this
this bar you know is around 147 148.
this bar finishes at 151 so it's
literally just minutes
if you don't have someone defending this
price with Supply up here
we're going to go higher
because now you don't have anyone
defending it
and what does it do it breaks through
and just shoots up past okay this level
here right you just draw that line again
you know just make it clear 44
all the way up above 400 and it did it
very quickly
right you're talking 55 okay it hit that
came off and then shot right back up
through it at 159
by 10 minutes later
we're trading all the way up here at
above 400 okay
but I mean you could have got you know
if you're getting long in here somewhere
around 50
because you know that once you break 50
right this level is 44.
break 50. it's Off to the Races it's a
quick 50 points in about five minutes
right it did go higher but I'm not
saying oh look you could have got how
many hundreds of you know 100 points out
of it should be happy with the 50. I
mean you could have got more obviously
we traded all the way up to 459 from 350
but
from here 50 all the way up into the
sideways activity here
you know is is a good opportunity
so anyway guys I hope you guys got
something out of this video you know
reading order flow is a thinking man's
game right it's as much as we love to
automate trading and I like to automate
trading you know I've got uh I'm working
on with some trading robots from another
company
um so you might see some videos on that
coming up
in the future but
if you're reading order flow it's
behooves you it's in your best interest
to you know understand
what's happening in the market and put
it together right you think use your use
logic okay and it's just going to give
you an insight and potential
it's going to give you insight into the
market and you know potential
opportunities
in pretty much any Market you know this
is mini dollar last week I talked a lot
about treasuries tens you know treasury
notes 10-year notes rather bonds
e-minis but now you know we're taking a
look at many Dow so a lot of the same
things would apply what what Market
you're looking at
so thanks everyone be sure to subscribe
to the channel and hit the like button
see you guys on the next video bye